in her new memoir stormy Daniels work
counts tonight she had sex with Donald
Trump he probably heard some of the
details she describes Trump's penis in
graphic detail she's calling it smaller
than normal and oddly shaped she goes on
to compare his penis to the Super Mario
mushroom character toad this is all real
this is what she said I'm just quoting
all this talk about the president's
penis shape is embarrassing for the
White House but get this it's good news
for a local food vendor right here in
Los Angeles his name is dick Mitchell
he runs a mushroom store he says since
the book came out business is booming
through the roof we have mr. Mitchell
with us tonight via satellite
hi Colin that looks like you're still at
your store right now is that right
yeah I can't get away business is
booming at mushroom dicks okay you know
send us the name of your store is
mushroom dicks yes I named it after
myself and what I sell okay
and you're saying these stormy Daniels
book increased your business is that
right Oh 100%
stormy Daniels book got people thinking
about mushroom dicks and hey that's the
name of my store so come on down and see
what we got you know we've got plenty of
things morels and chanterelles and
shiitakes and hey if you're looking for
truffle buddy you found it that's kind
of funny yeah yeah when you work with
mushrooms you got to be a fun guy hey
fun guy but seriously our republic has
hit a new low and it's not a question of
whether the country can survive but how
long it'll take us to recover our
dignity and return the national
conversation to a dialogue based on
shared ideals and the pursuit of the
common good mushroom day Nick Mitchell
everybody
[Applause]
you